oh good he's taking a drink of water I'm
going to get a question in
so
oh my God he's not swallowing
um
Harrison
[Laughter]
this behavior is not worthy of you a man
of your stature all you've achieved this
is not worthy we should also mention
that he's been eating those little
Little Cuties those little orange slices
this whole the smallest orange I've ever
seen make a tiny mini nectarine yeah a
tangible if you will and you've been
eating it section by section Little
Cuties yeah called yeah that's nice
that's what I do
are you glad he finally piped up yeah
yeah isn't this worth it incredible
comment about Little Cuties
great I think if we didn't have that I
think what would we do what would we do
trying to paint a picture for The
Listener I think that's very good if
only there were cameras here oh
um why are there cameras here this is
just for tax purposes I need to be able
to show that we made a podcast okay and
then we get to write it off because I
monetize everything I now own your
likeness because you've been on the
podcast and you need to buy it back from
me for the new Indiana Jones film to
come out
that's how smart I am that's what makes
me different from other people in this
business
I'm a real whiz Harrison a real whiz
wow
I uh I saw you at a party recently no
yeah I did I did I remember I saw you
too I said thank you I was glad you saw
me you're hard to miss I'm hard to miss
yeah I kind of stand out don't I stand
up
but I had a I just was in a silly mood
and it was fantastic because I walked up
to you and I said
I think I'm the new Harrison Ford and
you gave me that great look
and you said you I'm Harrison Ford
and I said well you've been Harrison
Ford for a long time but it's time for a
new one and it's me and you said okay
you can have it and I thought that was a
verbal agreement that maybe I take over
oh what a waste what are you talking
about I have the gravitas oh I have the
bearing what will you do with it
I would um
I would try to you know keep the
different franchises going oh no why you
is Han Solo yeah no
let's stop this right now
where was this party where was this a
lid started
it was a party alleged party you were
there
it's a party uh that was a lot of the
shrinking gang was there and yeah and
which by the way you are hilarious on
that show that's a that's a fantastic
part and uh you play it beautifully and
um
we had a uh we had a nice time at that
party a bunch of the shrinking cast was
there and uh I remember it now clearly
clearly you were there you were there
and uh I think you were having
maybe a tequila and I was having maybe a
little bit of uh orange juice okay it
was orange juice they're easily very
easy to mistake orange juice for
but anyway
um
I thought we had a real moment there I
thought uh and I thought that you
enjoyed my company and I hate to make
this all about me when you've had this
incredibly storied career
you know I know where you live
and it's not very far from where I live
you could
walk over to my house anytime is that
true
no because
I could walk to your house but would I
get in if the doorbell rang no you would
walk back
but at least you would at least you
would you'd make an effort I'd make an
effort and you know if you if you really
wanted me to
notice the roundness of this
if you really wanted me to be your
friend
but you didn't
and it's over now I had my chance no no
I think
I think this is your chance I think you
can still redeem yourself oh well how's
it going so far
[Laughter]
no I have I have actually I have friends
like you okay
really I mean you know circus people
whatever
laughs
no I you have no friends like me
I've always
liked you
I liked you that's why I did your show
many times many times yeah I did it like
what twice oh no four or five times you
did my show nine times you did my show
you have and you right here right my
name nine times did show up nine times
yeah
what you did it nine times
and you were unfailingly very funny
every time yeah and one of my favorite
things you ever did yeah
was we have this person who our fans
know very well named George Lansky who's
the Star Wars obsessive and he had built
a Millennium Falcon out of Legos and it
took him nine months to build this thing
yeah and he brought it out and gave a
long speech to you yeah about the
meaning of his Millennium Falcon one of
the pieces of memorabilia in my
collection in fact the flagship piece is
a Lego Millennium Falcon that I put
together in 2010. they're selling for
about five thousand dollars now and it
took about 60 man hours to create and I
display it with pride but it would
really mean the world to me if Harrison
could sign it is that okay Harrison wow
sure thank you guys so much thank you
wow now it's a very delicate a long time
yeah
[Applause]
that's bad
and handed it to you
and you threw it up over your head
and it landed on the floor and
it was the greatest day of my life and
then he picked up a piece and then
signed it and you signed it for him and
it was one of the greatest greatest
things I've ever seen in my life and by
the way it's a it's a clip online that
people adore they just adore it it was
it was just a magical magical moment and
I thank you for that well those of you
at home who
don't know how these things work let me
point out
that this was a scripted bit yes yes it
was
she didn't build the damn thing somebody
else okay in the prop Department this is
why I built the damn thing over a pro
you know probably took him three weeks
he probably had to take it home and and
ask his kid to help him put it together
yeah and then and then you built this
whole stick around it and you
made well I made suggested you suggested
that it would be funny yes if I if I
destroyed it yeah yeah right I do I will
make it clear and first of all this is
why you've never you were right it was
fun yeah
cruel cruel cruel I'm cruel but funny
um I'd like to point out that you'd be
terrible working with a magician
because the magician would come out and
do a trick where he saws the lady in
half and then puts her back together
again and just as the crowd is
applauding Harrison Ford walks out and
says excuse me
I'd like to point out that this was all
a sad sham
This Woman's secret herself into the
first half of the box and those fakes
are fake
I have picture you as a terrible
terrible magician's assistant but yes
you just exposed my little trick that
delighted millions and you've just
explained by people never do imitations
of me
I was just trying to get my voice into a
mail register that's all I was trying to
do
all I was trying to do
tried I tried the only way I can sound
like a man is to get down here
and then I'm either sin or Harrison for
and I am neither one